en californie un hôpital et vient d'être
inaugurée écoutez bien il a été baptisé
michael jackson children hospital bref
vrai ou faux les écoute et je rappelle
qu'ils aiment été condamné calmez-vous 1
attendez quoi il y aborde d'abord je
vous dis c'est faux pour les auteurs
très drôle s'armer concernant celle de
le 18 novembre la cour d'appel de
californie a rendu une décision
oui dans laquelle elle annonce
s'apprêtait annulé le non-lieu 2010 est
non voilà donc le procès va repartir
avec les deux garçons qui étaient dans
le vrai le tpm big fun mais c'est à dire
que ça va être un procès comment
s'appelle ans parce que le délai de
prescription en californie a été
rallongée ouais donc là ils peuvent
attaquer mais fédérer et c'était le
procès à 6
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attendez de l'honneur c'est quand même
essayer d'être c'était le procès qui
conseille dans lequel histoire
l'attouchement des deux garçons enfin
les mêmes les viols et de ses deux
garçons là qui ont fait le documentaire
qui est passé il ya quelques mois
effectivement on va pas non plus accuser
du coup ses enfants ou sa famille et
bagages car tout qu'est-ce qui pourrait
que ça serait un sacré à titre posthume
bah oui mais enfin au niveau de l'image
et 2 bien sûr il faut juste dire par
exemple que à droits d'auteur juste
c'est guillaume qui me lie club à avoir
des dédommagements peut-être mais
lorsque m6 a diffusé le documentaire sur
lui c'est ça en jésus ni aux états unis
documentaire il ya 13 % de ventes en
moins
il ya à l'ailé comme on dit allez les
mecs en fait les simpson ils ont retiré
un épisode dans lequel il était non non
non je tiens à dire c'est que s'il était
condamné mais titre posthume pour y
avoir de grosses grosses conséquences
financières pour la famille en attendant
que j'aime le documentaire qui passe
c'est 13% parce que ça serait peut-être
avéré ce que tout le monde dit pour le
moment là il n'a jamais été condamné
donc on sait pas si la hyène
condamnation de fait condamné mort enfin
la bombe
on a bien une médaille ou quoi ça c'est
important de savoir si oui ou non à se
défendre mais ça m'intéresse c'est le
king de la pop depuis depuis 40 ans et
est oui ou non une mauvaise bertin des
projets bien deux c'est bien de
reconnaître si après je reconnais que
c'est étonnant si tu peux pas te
déranger paraît très très étonnant un
procès ou peut être plus mais je n'ai
jamais vu mais ça serait le premier en
tout cas bravo monde sébastien pour
cette information tpm people merci
beaucoup